Dwayne the rock Johnson can kind of do
it all successfully transitioning from a
career as one of the most popular and
accomplished wrestling stars of all time
he's gone on to a Hollywood career that
spanned everything from action flicks
like The Fast & Furious franchise to
family films like the Tooth Fairy to
comedies like Central Intelligence
Johnson is a likable guy who always
seems happy to be wherever he is and he
never takes himself too seriously
particularly on movie sets here's a look
at some bloopers that make us love the
rock even more walking tall Johnson is
tough the kind of guy who could easily
smash things without the need for
special props or stuntmen to do the
dirty work for him at least one would
think that would be the case when the
wrestler was cast in one of his first
major lead roles as Chris bond jr. in
the 2004 remake of the 70s classic
walking tall he discovered that his
toughest enemy wasn't a bad guy at all
but rather a particularly obstinate car
taillight I'm strong I swear journey to
the mysterious island a not so little
known fact about Dwayne the rock Johnson
dude is seriously jacked his muscles are
absurdly large so on the set of journey
to the mysterious island he decided to
let his body do the talking instead of
his mouth - hilarious effect
the game plan it's almost like Johnson
went Fulton method actor with this
blooper in the game plan he plays a star
quarterback who's thrust into the
wackiness of fatherhood upon suddenly
learning he has an 8 year old daughter
but as it turns out there are certain
pitfalls involved in having a tea party
when you're as massive as the rock small
chair big guy classic the other guys it
looks like Johnson had cold feet when it
came time to film this big scene in the
cop comedy the other guys in which he
briefly co-starred opposite samuel
l.jackson the two extra awesome
detectives end up jumping off a building
at least they're supposed to Central
Intelligence
in this clip Johnson shows he's not too
tough to take a little ribbing after he
admits to the character played by
comedian Kevin Hart that his name is
made up Hart gives him the pep talk
arguing that having a made-up name isn't
such a big deal Hart thin rattles off a
bunch of cool names that everybody knows
aren't real including someone very
familiar to Johnson do you think mr.
team and sting in the rock you think
those guys are real that's a bunch of
dumbass nicknames by a bunch of dumbass
be the tooth fairy well there's a
magazine for everything and everyone
even tooth fairies in this blooper from
the set of the family-friendly comedy
the tooth fairy in which Johnson plays
against type as tooth fairy he shows
that he's still a man a man with needs
race to Witch Mountain Johnson keeps the
mood light and shows that he has some
pretty agile improv comedy skills for a
guy best known for big and flashy action
movies during the filming of this Disney
remake Johnson yells out the names of a
bunch of different animals in an attempt
to distract another character including
one very dangerous animal in particular
ferret kangaroo
Vin Diesel guys better-looking Fast Five
speaking of Vin Diesel here's Johnson
messing around on the set of Fast Five
he's only pretending to mercilessly
pummeling diesel about the head and face
over and over again though according the
internet rumor he probably wishes he had
unloaded for real when he had the chance
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]